ce que je constate depuis mon petit
point de vue c'est que si j'avais eu
accès effectivement plus facilement à ne
serait-ce qu des vêtements sans parler
de l'irréversibilité ne serait ce qu'à
la possibilité de réfléchir à changer de
prénom quand j'étais jeune ça aurait été
trois tentatives de suicide en moins ça
aurait été un sentiment d'inadéquation
en moins je le constate aussi on a
encore
perdu une jeune femme trans qui avait
clairement le sentiment de ne pas
pouvoir exister et je crois que
finalement au-delà de d'un parti pris
idéologique au delà de positionnement
politique cette réalité de je ne me sens
pas le droit d'exister elle doit juste
être entendu humainement ensuite on doit
lui trouver des outils il ya des outils
sociaux qui existent ensuite et des
outils médicaux qui existe j'ai le droit
en tant qu individu majeur et éclairé de
décider que des choses seront faites qui
seront irréversibles pour moi je je je
crois que c'est pas un droit qui est
abusive je crois qu'il ne fait de mal à
personne d'autre parce que je crois que
ce mouvement de
2,2 de conversion dont on entend parfois
parler finalement il est largement
surestimée qu'il existe une panique des
personnes si ce genre des personnes
entrant face à la possibilité d'une
libre expression de notre minorité et
que finalement ça ça on utilise
l'argument du corps on lui utilise
l'argument du sexe comme une sorte de
2,2 d'appel au bon sens d'appel à la
nature alors que bien souvent ce qui a
demandé n'est pas du tout de cet ordre
là j'aimerais que ça soit entendu je
crois que ça l'est trop
oui
[Musique]